so today we're going to be asking people  who they think  looks more successful outfit  and because he's wearing a school shirt  adam for sure he got a satchel bag you  dripped out bro  do you think it's because i'm a guy no  you might be biased but honestly yeah  i got my bros so why didn't you vote for  hannah yeah oh you got the  mizzou okay my mic turned off here but  you're just gonna have to take my word  that both of them  said me well probably you  just you're clothing you're not in  joggers and sweatpants  you got the sweatpants on college  t-shirt  any there's anything we could improve  our looks maybe a nice  button-up shower some new shoes i'd go  with  leather i guess like you're the one  that's interviewing us so that kind of  makes you  more at the end of the day who's more  successful  neither of us we're both